okay so this is web weirdos a title I
think we know a lot about the web
weirdos ourselves but this is an episode
that has Bobcat Goldthwait and who's the
female spider Deena don't know offhand
okay well who doesn't have a distinctive
voice I'm sure someone will yell at us
and be like you didn't point that person
but all right this is about two spiders
who can't fit a Jake in their web well
not really catch they sort of fling
themselves into the web and yeah pretty
much they come along and they have like
you know this just camera again I got my
two seconds I'm gone now I just had to
make it every single video he doesn't do
this till the camera goes on it's
really weird it's actually true so if
something in this big argument and the
Finn and Jake are trying to help the
male spider with his relationship and it
was in a bar but that's it yeah and
telson go get a gift while they try to
figure out a way to get out and he
brings a gift but barb doesn't like it
and they get in this big fight and then
she gives birth and Finn and Jake escape
swimming through all their babies and I
guess it's a happy ending but I don't
know what this is an episode I probably
shouldn't lie guys you're privy oh yeah
just kind of Monday whatever but for
some reason I really enjoyed it there is
I think there's something to something
about that relationship I genuinely like
I don't know why it's really
dysfunctional and it's really crazy but
I guess I I just admired the fact that
they're both trying to kind of make it
work they're just not very good at it
yeah oh and I love I really like Bobcats
voice what he's you know he's not doing
his Zed or whatever his name was from
police academy boys um you know he's
actually this very I mean for everything
you see and very soft-spoken edits I
think it works
um and
I think just the animation to the way
they move while talking about their
relationship and stuff but it's therapy
giant monsters and they're really tiny
they're not like like per point I mean
they're like hard dark colors and it
makes them look all the more funny when
they're talking about this kind of stuff
and I think also I think I like to in
this could because I just saw a
documentary on Calvin Hobbes called dear
mr. waters but we haven't seen it but I
think it just hit me the etching Finn
and Jake are a lot like Calvin and
Hobbes the more I think about I really
feel like because you got you know a
finn is kind of like Calvin and Hobbes
is kind of like Jake and they're just
these two best buds to sort of make up
these adventures I think the one for me
just the opening one he's coming through
and Jake's like yeah he does all these
weird stunts and flips and turns and all
these things and then Finn's like
stunned and he tries it and of course
doesn't do anything remotely close but
he feels like he did like in his head
it's like yeah I'm awesome and that's
just that's such a Calvin moment for me
and I'm just watching it's like yeah
there is just sort of this great passion
for just energy and imagination why to
do stuff and I don't know maybe that's
part of why I like them so much you look
like you strongly disagree with that
none I mean it's like that like what you
are we like Calvin and Hobbes like the
amount of energy you have over like
doing the videos you're like yeah I'm
just like it's a video yeah I'm sure
that's what you are you don't read at
all no actually no really you yeah I
guess I am more anime you're more just
kind of a like yo Angela you are
definitely more like Hobbes you're all
over the place good yeah okay Calvin
it's the one that's the energized one
Hobbes is the more no but then again
like you said Hobbes just like and I
think swim bouncing off look you don't
get your story straight you know maybe I
should maybe it has nothing to do with
Calvin Hobbs at all maybe I should just
not make that comparison in the least
maybe it's like Nancy Kerrigan and time
you heard it that's like the thing you
just want your game over here this is
we're not all gonna talk about venture
time we're gonna talk about the stuff
that we saw before we did this V long
the documentaries the documentaries that
is weird that we both watched
documentaries before watching Adventure
Time mine wasn't by choice I did get
lulled into it I did start enjoying it
but it was not good for us and you're
even saying like how we gonna get like
Tonya Harding jokes in this and I just
did you just did it nicely done so no I
think you're completely right though
this is kind of one of those weird
episodes where it's like right when it
gets that blood where you're like I'm
kind of done with it it kind of picks
back up yeah it like it doesn't feel
like you should like it but you just
kind of do especially like he finds the
solar they say it's not just the sorts
of magic so much of course it's like
what what's the story behind that sword
a lion the skeleton that had it and and
he goes and when the wennbar doesn't
like it you you were kind of like why
don't you like it's like I don't know
why I was really into that relationship
I was really like no come on you used to
like it you should okay maybe he doesn't
know you but he's trying he's like give
him a chance it's like I don't know I
lived in when we got into the
relationship for some reason I see it as
more of like it's a very generic
relationship filled with like cliches of
like nachos and all that stuff where the
guy gets a gift but of course the woman
only sees it as oh you got this for
yourself you didn't actually get this
for me and he's like no we totally got
him by the fire like no that's no way
you got it or like you know I'm
providing for you and she's like well I
would too but you don't like the way I
do it yeah I like that too of that you
know it's it's different with guys -
it's not listen to you lady he's trying
to get out but he's giving him
legitimately good advice - well don't
forget about the birds yeah the birds
was good yeah him spinning all the birds
into one lands it is and they were like
I think finally began it and it pulls by
and there's all these birds covered in
spit everywhere Elsa this is the first
time ever
wonder if anyone else like thought about
this one they saw this episode this is
the first time I'm actually questioning
what is glob I don't know before it was
like Oh My glob you think ok just it's
like gosh it's just a replacement for
God so they could swear it but it's like
you know glob be with you go with glob
and something like wait is there
actually a koala like I never thought
about it now I'm like what the hell is
glob cuz they never actually reference
glob is like you know this figure you
know or an element to be with you or
something guiding you it is always just
Oh My glob but now it's like you know it
could be like you know this spiritual
being or something we don't know do they
you know have to say what they do if
they do but do they go into glob yeah
did you think Oh into glove um no you do
find out what glove is what or who glob
is there is a reveal and that's all I'm
gonna say okay yeah I actually I don't
want to know any more IB because that's
like I said I mean before you just think
it's sort of like a replacement word and
then it's again
I'm wonder if they sir came across the
same thing where it's like it's like Oh
crabapples you know instead of crap you
know what
oh my glove but I'm wondering just they
kept saying it's like you know what is
clapping we should make a calab made
there should be like the almighty claw
or something in this universe and
they're gonna have fun with that so I'm
actually looking forward to what glob is
well remember there's also they say oh
my Grod oh is that a blob oh my I
remember the recipe III didn't ever grab
that that's what I it may be a hurried I
just forgot it kind of comes up and you
they they say and there's four different
ones that they always consistently say
okay battle the gloves wrap up the
gloves is that the title they be called
wrath of the gloves no okay cool
they are bringing tails I'm sure they'll
make one better than that but yeah I
don't really know it's pretty generic
well I guess web weirdos yeah there's a
bad title it's like a million fairy
tales you could get dads don't you it
was a good time
what the hell is that um but I thought
was good episode no I liked it
um damn cat sorry being distracted by
the cat but this cat will just like go
into the coin that come out and just be
like you know he'll have something I'm
just I'm gonna play at this this doesn't
distract you does it doesn't this
doesn't distract you does it doesn't
he's a little turd no he comes out of my
daughter's bedroom with a puzzle piece
drops it picks it up drops it again
sorry I got distracted I do apologize
blame the cat is that our monkeys
adorable bring the clothes your bedroom
door yes the psychos for me I liked what
weirdoes it was fine it was cute I like
the fact that bobcat did not use his
normal voice or that everybody knows
it's remember I'm like oh that's Bobcat
and you're like you sure I'm like wait
let me check to make sure you know
because I'm so used to in the artists he
hasn't done it in years though I think
like if you look at like as IMDB page
Mikey's really gone behind the cameras
just directing a lot like he's done a
ton of TV shows really fun um and he's
directing one or two movies but like his
big thing was he was doing TV for a
while and everyone that's why I talked
about an interview or something is like
yeah he's actually really soft spoken to
the ADEs and he finally got tired of it
yeah I'm glad too good for you about get
good for you